retour du moule burn but maillot de bain
collant pour les garçons
comme les crocs les marcels ou encore la
coupe mulet il a fallu attendre que et
bien le slip de bain atteigne vraiment
son pic de ringarde pour qu'il revienne
à la mode et c'est le Figaro qui prédit
son grand retour donc cet été à la plage
à la piscine tenez vous prêt Gilles tu
parles tu pars en vacances demain en
plus oui
là c'est vraiment tout a déjà vu comme
ça ben non c'est la première fois mais
elle va me découvrir en même temps mais
là c'est Mira peur mi footballeur alors
là
c'est surtout très moche
selon Le Figaro se sous-vêtement qui a
souvent été associé à la communauté gay
plein maintenant aux jeunes
hétérosexuels qui pour plus de 40%
d'entre eux des 16 25 ans il soulève
maintenant de la compte donc pour eux le
slip de Ben devient un accessoire idéal
perçu comme coquet et viril bien sûr
cette beauté
idéale pour exhiber entre autres leur
jambe galbée résultat
tu m'as dit je te masserai ce soir
du coup il faut que je te masse
du coup dans notre couple
de temps un début et je ferai la fin
plus tard
M Pokora sur quoi tu cliques en secret
en secret moi j'ai les vidéos des
ostéopathes ouais vous savez les gars
qui font craquer j'aime trop ça
je mets mes écouteurs pour bien entendre
en fait c'est
je sais pas j'aime trop ça en fait je
constate sur les plages de France et de
Navarre des gens qui exhib fièrement des
corps manifestement sans contrôle
sont tenus on sent des années des mois
et des mois de de saucisson de bière de
de fromage fondu qui viennent ensuite
montrer sur la plage moi j'aime pas les
gens se tiennent garde un vêtement une
chemise
je vois que ben il est quand même affûté
et un peu musclé aussi
il a un bon petit cul rond
les gens qui sont là à attraper des
cancers de la peau comme ça ils sont
tout rose etc c'est pas possible et
tenez vous sur la plage soyez discrets
soyez élégants
obligés d'être là avec vos coups de
soleil votre moulebeat alors
short 3 élégants maillot de bain voilà
que j'achète avenue Montaigne elles ont
entre 84 et 99 ans et la Tour Eiffel
aujourd'hui c'est un peu leur Everest
327 marches rose est la première de
cordée et toute se tiennent à la rente
pour se donner du courage
prenez votre temps
en haut ça faisait longtemps que j'avais
une relation avec quelqu'un de très très
présent ça me fait du bien
donc
sauf que il y a 6 mois en boîte j'ai
rencontré une fille Raya on est devenu
super proche et en fait cette fille il
s'avère que c'est l'ex de Yanis
casse-tête
on va se marier dans quelques semaines
et
smattez-moi ce sera Aurélie l'ex de grec
c'est ma meilleure amie que mon ex la
mère de mes trois enfants serait la
témoin de ma nouvelle femme
j'aurais jamais cru
moi je pense qu'on va sortir de là
tout ça moi j'en suis sûr
ce soir on dort ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a un endroit et un envers à ton
costume
en fait
[Musique]
mes amis
ce matin rose est arrivé la première
en 30 minutes seulement au premier étage
de la Tour Eiffel
[Applaudissements]
a mis 10 minutes de plus que Rose
elle arrive la dernière mais l'important
pour elle c'était de réussir cette
explorer
[Musique]
assumer les choses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a des otaries gamer parce que des
otaries ou les lions mer adorent aussi
des jeux vidéo la preuve avec Spike qui
maîtrise parfaitement cette console
regardez spécialement créée pour pour
lui avec quatre curseurs verts qui peut
bouger avec son museau juste pour
pouvoir avoir le labyrinthe et éviter le
petit poisson et quand il gagne et ben
il a un poisson en vrai une vidéo
accélérée qui nous aide à visualiser la
rotation de la Terre
c'est ce qu'on appelle un effet
gyroscopique
ces images splendides ont été filmées à
l'aide d'une caméra qui utilise un
moteur pour rester sur un axe précis
l'appareil c'est tout simplement fixé
sur un point de la Voie lactée et
s'adapte au mouvement de notre planète
pour nous offrir ce spectacle à couper
le souffle